hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey
we're gonna watch today from the awesome
channel looper the best MCU Easter eggs
you never noticed before
I'm excited check this out as I
constantly miss Easter eggs all the time
even when they're right in front of my
face I've missed 100% of these eggs in
the Marvel Universe
well people before we hop into this
video I want to give a shout out to
today's video sponsor and that is floppy
bird yeah big thanks to them for
sponsoring this video
so floppy bird is an arcade style app
game available on iOS and Android and
this game is the epitome of simple yet
addictive
seriously I sit down just to check out
this game so I could write up this
shoutout here and I wound up playing for
a half an hour and unlock two birds so
it is really very easy to hook by this
game plus what their latest update
floppy bird 4.0 is better than ever the
game itself is pretty straightforward
choose either standard or extreme mode
then tap to make your little birdie jump
and try to wreck I was any points as you
can without dying brave fire toxic
sludge and spikes as you make your way
between the pipes time your hops just
right so you can collect coins and
unlock new characters and the best part
is it's free to download free to use and
surprisingly challenging to play so
download flappy bird today challenge
your friends see who can clinch the high
score or consult the leader bird wobble
board to see where you rank across the
world of floppy bird players and and end
don't forget to use our link right here
or in the description box to download
the app today thanks floppy bird Thank
You floppy bird
all right we're not gonna do the
reaction anymore I just wanted to say
that there's almost a countless number
of Easter eggs scattered across the
movies of the seu some are self they all
take place to become more obvious like
this and all these are a few that you
might have just missed three years ago
we'll see The Avengers and the x-men
have kept separate on the big screen
thanks for conflict and usage rights
between various studios well the
Avengers or Marvel Studios the mutants
have their own adventures over at Fox
but that doesn't mean there haven't been
any knowing they look like the
adventures yes his AI assistant Jarvis
what the opposite record is for a very
specific plane as the model for the jet
flown to missions by the x-men oh yeah
no I can't exactly specify that a stark
was referring seniors private super
plane but it wasn't us not
fans nonetheless that's in America the
First Avenger takes Marvel fans back to
World War two not only the erequest
Steve Sarris became Captain America but
also the time during which the character
was created in real life but he wasn't
the only Supergirl to come out of this
period during the stark Expo scene
eagle-eyed viewers will be able to spot
another classic Marvel character who was
created back when the company was still
known as timely comics Steve Bucky and
their dates walk through the expo they
pass a glass display case with a costume
in it labeled dr. phinius for he
presents the sympathetic man oh cool
scientists who created the original
Human Torch all the way back in 100
comics number one this character who was
initially kept in a glass cylinder much
like the one in Captain America remains
an important piece of the foundations of
the Marvel Universe
this particular shot establishes that
some version of him
the MCU at some point so maybe one day
we'll flashback again and get the full
story of synthetic man and his emission
I don't think we will definitely are in
the realm of Marvel Entertainment which
itself contains a vast multiverse of
various worlds featuring many ultimate
versions of its characters the MCU even
has its own designated reality number
one nine nine nine nine nine miss places
that within the greater Marvel Universe
meaning that whether we'll ever see it
or not there's a cosmic link between the
cinematic versions of these characters
and their prime continuity comic book
counterparts are sized in Thor the dark
world when Erik Selvig laid out his
understanding of reality on giant
chalkboard during his time in a mental
institution among his scribblings are
the words six months six universe the
official versus oh how fascinating Oh
Stan Lee yeah can I have my shoe back
although Stan Lee's cameos and Marvel
movies have become
legendary we isn't the only Marvel
luminary to pop up in the MCU at one
point or another one of the most notable
instances of his fame came during
Captain America the Winter Soldier as
Alexander Pierce is questioning the
Winter Soldier a team of handlers are
standing around the road one of them
seen on the left is edy Brubaker
an Eisner award-winning comic book
writer responsible for resurrecting
Bucky Barnes as the Winter Soldier in
Captain America number one back in 2005
before Brubaker joined Captain America
Bucky had been dead for decades and was
long considered one of the rare comics
characters who had never returned from
the grave without roux Baker the MCU
would be a very different place to eat
so it's nice to see him get a little
moment of recognition here no Easter
eggs in the entirety of the MCU is quite
as bountiful as the collectors hideaway
on my way the guardians of the galaxy
his massive treasure trove of artifacts
and living specimen seems to go on
forever and if you're willing to be a
little liberal with the pause button
you're likely to notice quite a few
interesting things the Burroughs any
welcome let us see what you brought
among these items are a Chitauri warrior
from the dark elf from Thor the dark
world where Ozma that's based off and of
course Howard the Duck however there's
one more fine tucked away in that room
they
Lyde reaching implications for the
future of the MCU it's possible to spot
a certain cocoon-like object that writer
director James Gunn later hinted was the
gestation place of Adam warlock
realities in a post-credits scene from
volume 2 as it turns out the two objects
might not be the exact same cocoon but
the visual cues are difficult to ignore
Adam warlock has massive cosmic
implications for Marvel's future so if
he does show up at some point we can
probably tie it all back to this
I can't wait for James Gunn to bring it
back oh yeah it's gonna be great
Guardian Captain America Civil War at
Peggy Carter's funeral her niece Sharon
delivers the eulogy and passes on some
words of wisdom her aunt once shared
with her even if the whole world is
telling you to move it is her duty to
plant yourself like a tree look them in
the eye and say no it's a powerful
moment for certain comic book readers
however it was made all the more
powerful when the fact that it's a
speech lifted largely from amazement
notified
a comic time into the original Civil War
event in which a very similar speech is
given by none other than Captain America
himself the screenwriters Christopher
Markus Stephen McFeely definitely did
their homework with this one some Easter
eggs may begin as an amusing idea but
sadly just don't come together and fail
to ever reach a satisfying payoff in the
NC you where some parts of the universe
are attempting to work with the same
concepts as others this can happen a lot
for example it was the case with one
particular hidden gem in dr. strange
which has been semi red conned by the
events of who whose Runaways TV series
and various points in the film we see
glimpses of the hong kong sanctum where
sorcerers work to guard that particular
corner of the world from a host of
magical threats a motive is a staff
wielding character named Tina
Minoru Linda Louise Duan we only know
her name because she's listed in the
credits but minora happens to be the
mother of meat nori
one of the main stars
yourself of course Tina menorah was
recast for one aways but it's still a
nice touch
some marvel characters I didn't realize
that I've seen at least a brief
appearance in the MCU one instance of
this happening occurs two Picador
Ragnarok when we see the Grand Master's
palace once a car for the first time
this towering structure is adorned with
various shimmering statues depicting the
heads of champions who have fought in
the arena and while the hook head under
construction might end up dominating the
whole thing the heads that have already
been built are particularly fascinating
for comic book fans they include by
beast man Vic Aries and even made an
ally of Thor who fans have been hoping
to see on the big screen for years we
may not see any of these characters
actually living and breathing in the MCU
anytime soon but these statues were
enough to let us know they exist and
that's a good start Avengers infinity
war is very loosely based on the 1991
Marvel Comics event series the Infinity
Gauntlet while the plot of the movie
differs significantly from its origin
story the film bears many nods and
weights to the text for example Bruce
Banner crashes through the roof of dr.
Strange's sanctum echoing the moment
when the Silver Surfer did the same
thing in the comics
I understand that rounds gauntlet fans
happy however one that really stands out
comes in the films very last shot when
Santos sits down the humble thought to
watch the Sun Rise on a grateful
universe as he walks through the hut
you'll see something standing under the
crops growing outside a scarecrow made
from his old battle armor at the end of
Infinity Gauntlet vanos gives up his
quest for ultimate power after the
battle picks up farming and makes a
scarecrow with his armor yeah I know
that says scarecrow yeah that's a good
video
yeah actually those were surprising yeah
that was a great video yeah man I props
to whoever sits here in scours all these
movies I mean just goes to show you two
how the MCU I don't know if the MCU will
be around forever but they'll never be
short of ideas or characters no no or
different takes to to bring to them or
different realms to go to young with
stuff like that I mean there are endless
comics to mash together and that's
pretty cool out from the very first MCU
official film that there was a nod to
the x-men right there yeah I never
picked up on that I never will all the
countless times I've seen the first Iron
Man yeah never noticed that one specific
moment how funny Kevin Feige isn't
wanting it all along yeah man that was
the first harbinger of the Fox deal it
seems like you know every time you hear
about Fox and the Disney burger fight
you just talk about what do you mean it
seems like positive about a good new we
have no dude yo do you guys were nodding
them in the very first movie if there's
one thing you got to think Thor the dark
world for though the whole thing with a
6-1-6 universe oh yeah
you know what screw that I like Thor the
dark world I know everyone hates that
movie I like the 6.6 Universe thing I've
never heard of that we have our own
separate universe of the MCU was showing
that they in some way it co it's not
just based on the comics that it's got
its own time liners and junction with
the comics you know which is actually
even cooler that's very neat to me I
actually really appreciate that little
linkage right there I've never noticed
that no I mean either I mean everybody
notice the scribbling on it but going
into the MCU movies especially now
keep my eyes like on a swivel in case
there's anything in the background that
I might be able to catch and that's
actually a piece of the comics that
through research over time I have picked
up on a little bit and I thought that
Marvel has done a really great job of
translating the comic book vibe to the
big screen so it's cool to know that
they are all kind of linked and I guess
in a way that makes the possibilities to
me broader to know that it factors into
the greater just universe of all of
Marvel Adam warlock in the comic book
the main character that helps with
actually taking down Thanos
mm-hm and so I really thought you know
it would be neat if he came at the end
of the first infinity war as a tease but
then I do kind of feel it might detract
a little bit in terms of the build up of
the characters we've spent so much time
with and they're going up against their
ultimate enemy and their solution would
be introducing a new character instead
of them figuring out a way to take down
Thanos so I'm actually kind of glad they
don't know if he's gonna be in the next
Avengers movie obviously supposedly he's
not going to be they've been teasing him
and building him up even though when
James Gunn was with Disney and Marvel he
was still saying yeah we were actually a
real plans for Adam warlock whose what I
keep teasing him in every single movie
loved list videos part of it would
really open up the horizon in the
expansion of the cosmic section of the
MCU if you were to throw Adam warlock in
here it would change a lot and it would
be a much easier solution of beating
Thanos yeah I'm actually glad that we
haven't gotten him just yet I would like
him to be in here he's kind of he's a
weird character and he's a really
powerful character so I'm hoping he does
come into play but for now I'm cool he's
not in here first I was thinking he
would be in Indian the last couple
Avengers movie but now I'm like it I'm
actually too cool with him not being in
it oh yeah I'm with Captain Marvel
coming up to and all the hype around her
level of immense power and you know the
effect she's going to have on the MCU
I'm sure they want to hold off on
something I got a warlock until they
need another shot yeah you know remember
the character's name I've seen Runaways
and the Asian girl yeah and her mom it
was cool about runaways as their parents
are also just as important as the kid
care if it was like they really do share
the screen and them and the show so
that's a neat Easter Egg to me but I
wonder why she wasn't pointed out and
the movie must be some deleted scene in
Doctor Strange especially we're gonna
read it to character in the cuz they're
in looper they said that they only know
that characters in here because of the
credits so it must have been a deleted
scene or they just gave some featured
Asian extra the title name so they could
have a little Easter Egg in there in the
credit sequences this character is
technically yeah or were they like you
know we're gonna make Runaways and we
want her in here so can you cut her out
of the movie about I don't think Marvel
movies but it just for some Hulu show
yeah yeah listen up Marvel we got an
operation here we're gonna talked about
show everyone talks about run away yeah
yeah yep especially since the
cloak-and-dagger came the guys run away
is actually a great show yeah I really
recommend that show the heads I thought
was gonna cool you know the tower of
this video just goes to show you can't
read into too much o MCU everything as
drinking is an easter egg and it's
detailed out I didn't even think like oh
those heads are or who that is but then
the second they popped up on screen
before she even said anything I was like
oh this is training my eye for next time
and I thought all those characters they
talked about seemed pretty cool I
definitely would want to see Thor's
buddy that they talked about just for
the design alone yeah I love that sort
of like narrow skull like face kind of
looks like Alec Baldwin from Beetlejuice
when he transforms his face my memory
for comic books tense is doing go pretty
fast
maybe it's because of certain things I
put into my lungs just makes reading so
much yeah that makes the colors haha
he's really glad you don't remember the
Scarecrow I remember the Scarecrow
moment and I remember
him being on a planet I'm being on the
farm at the end of Infinity Gauntlet
like I remember watching it in the
theatres going
oh yeah the snap that's what happens in
the comic and then watching the farm but
I've never noticed this scary I've seen
him infinity war three times that I had
never noticed that scarecrow in the
corner this just goes to show you me
I'm sure the grass is something yes it's
actually grass that was transplanted
here from the field where Odin died the
same ledge just reimagine what I really
want is a spin-off starring that that
scarecrow you know that's like if you
can use the glove to bring the Scarecrow
to life you just have a fan of a
scarecrow no this is kicking it at home
that's my the comics we all attend like
let's attack a minute ago sir did it
hollow inside why we spend 20 minutes
beating this thing up it's still wiped
out half the universe explain that to me
alright guys well are there other Easter
eggs that we may have missed
no definitely not no I think loopers got
them all covered yeah that's it Alton
well you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
Belvin don't forget to go to that
description box and download the floppy
bird app today I'm telling you guys
total blast blast blast blast blast